[Musique]
charline et alain
salut luthérienne
j'espère que vous êtes passé une bonne
semaine moi non
paul mccartney s'est marié laineux n'est
pas venu
ce soir en père nous accueillons michel
drucker
michel ricard bonsoir bonsoir thiery
bienvenue sur le plateau de salut les
terriens michel je suis très flatté de
recevoir le parrain de la télé corleone
le taulier donne drucker
tu te souviens avant je t'appelais
terminator
michel si tu nous regardes habitait là
en p2 nous accueillerons anne hidalgo
hidalgo première adjointe de bertrand
delanoë le maire de paris porte parole
de martine aubry anne hidalgo qui nous
dira qu'elle n'est pas la fille de
michel hidalgo et qu'il faut arrêter de
lui parler tout le temps de france
allemagne 82 ça la gonfle toujours en p2
nous accueillerons orelsan
orelsan le rappeur qui est passé de
morceaux comme sale [ __ ] à la petite
marchande de porte clés
si ça continue il va finir chez drucker
orelsan nous parlera de son nouvel album
le chant des sirènes voilà enfin on paie
3 après le zapping guillon nous
accueillerons notre invité du samedi 20
heures ce soir nicole damaggio et sa
fille anne claire
une mère et sa fille atteinte du
syndrome d'asperger celui de rain man
pour leur livre une épée dans la brume
chez anne carrière voilà l'émission
s'appelle salut les terriens
chez rocard aux branches war vous êtes
une sorte de lien vivant entre le rtf et
youtube
quand j'ai commencé à la télé les
beatles étaient deux fois plus nombreux
à michel
mézy vue ouais en 64 cindy lopes sylvie
vartan à l'olympia
je vous fais quoi maintenant michel 69 e
oui je viens de passer ce cap je
m'approche du cette année érotique un
érotique bien sûr un
69 ans pour un mec dont le père
s'appelait abraham c'est pas si vieux
final fou c'est vrai c'est bien de
parler de lui il va y avoir un film il
va y avoir un film de qu'est ce qu'on va
faire de toi réside par jean daniel
verhaeghe le casting se termine
maintenant ce que je sais c'est que ces
six mois carillon à va jouer mon père
alors michel nous allons parler de
france 2 vous animez vivement dimanche
et champs elysées d'europe 1 où vous
animez faites entrer l'invité de la
soirée 300 choeurs pour plus de vie que
vous animez lundi soir sur france 3
michel vous expliquer le principe de la
retraite vous n'êtes pas obligés de
travailler tout 28 vous savez ça qu'on a
mais mon modèle étanche à la savourer
jean piat avec j'ai encore de la marge
ah oui alors on commence avec france 2
dont vivement dimanche à 14h15 et
vivement dimanche prochain à 18h50 ça
marche très bien
c'est la douzième année et je me lasse
pas du tout et puis j'ai l'impression
que je m'améliore je crois que je
progresse et moi je suis c'est le louche
quand il parle de moi c'est un vieux
copain et 10 drucker c'est 1 1
un tardif qui a commencé tôt tout arrive
tard ouais ouais j'en suis pas encore au
au piercing à la coke mais ça
marche bien c'est pas comme le reste
qu'est ce qui se passe à france de
michel pas ce qui se passe pas un jour
sans qu'on lise un papier assassin dans
la presse beaucoup de choses nouvelles
et il faut du temps donner du temps au
temps quand on change d émission qui
était là depuis très longtemps animé par
des gens qui étaient identifiés
ça fait beaucoup donc il faut du temps
mais il faut pas non plus exagérer je
reprends un petit peu la tribune dans le
monde de monsieur philippe blain il ya
comme des choses qui marchent bien et
puis c'est le service public si services
publics tendent pas des trucs sympas
laboratoire il n'a pas de rendre des
comptes tous les jours à la ménagère de
moins de 50 ans donc on n'a pas nous à
s'adresser aux téléspectateurs en termes
de consommateurs alors vous avez vu
l'émission de delarue non ça serait bien
qu'ils se remettent à la drogue de
l'argent
ils sont servis gay ghsr ce quelqu'un
qui l'aurait vu ça se tourne chez moi à
au studio gabriel désigné pour un an oui
absolument mais vous savez il faut être
très modeste à la télévision comme dit
d'affi ce que tu croises en montant
l'escalier c'est les mêmes que tu
croises en descendre oui
non si tu nous regardes michel drucker
laurent j'ai vu les bonobos oui mais j'y
vais je vais retenir ses marques et u11
3 mai qu'un aveugle a mis un sou qui
veulent viser
laurent baffie bon alors michel si vous
étiez présent du service public est-ce
que vous reprendriez franz-olivier
giesbert guillaume durand mireille dumas
ce sont des ce sont des prouve vraiment
mais cela dit je touche du bois je suis
encore là mais je peux comprendre qu'un
patron arrive il dit voilà au change car
non mais ça que j'étais arrivé quand
philippe guillôme est arrivé il a livré
car il est trop fort nous non moi
c'était beaucoup plus violent que ça ils
début des jeux dans la maison et au
moment où ma femme dany ouvre la porte
avec les cafés elle entend écouter
michel joux parler franchement vous êtes
un homme du passé la télévision de
demain ne passera pas par vous cru qu
elle referme la porte et réchauffe le
café et bien
ma femme le fusille du regard ne restent
pas je suis en âge j'ai 45 ans 46 ans je
prends via et jeudi il a peut-être
raison je suis totalement hagard jeu le
raccompagne à l'ascenseur j'avais rendez
vous avec deux par dit on partait faire
sans utiliser avec gérard aux états unis
et là il me dit un truc terrible dans
l'ascenseur une scène de film il est
dans l'ascenseur il me dit écoute et ne
perdez pas le moral vous allez continuer
champs-elysées pendant un an et former
un jeune homme
j'arrive à roissy je tombe selon gérard
1 qui avait déjà fait pipi avant de
monter dans l'avion
c'est qui me dit papa fut un coup de
boule à 100 q les jeudis temps dira
tuera comme ça et gérard depardieu et je
lui dois ça quand on s'est posé à nos
graves il m'a dit tu appelles francis
bouygues devant moi et tu donne
rendez-vous en aval à cinq jours a pour
l'heure quatre saisons tf1
michel drucker
est ce que ces quatre hommes et services
publics pour établissez les speakerines
j'aime bien j'aime bien l'oeil de
monsieur frôle y faites moi un gros plan
des yeux tirés regardez faites moi un
groupe l'envoie là voyez là là il n'a
pas besoin de souffler on sait tous ce
qu'ils pensent
mais les speakerines c'est un grand
souvenir ouais d'ailleurs quand ils ont
repris sur tf1 tournez manège ben je
regrette qu'ils aient pas pris celle du
début ouais c'était vachement bien moi
j'étais amoureux de jacqueline huet il
ya un problème vous êtes patron du
service public vous faites quoi pour la
coiffure de pujadas
je suis un peu plus mobile quand même
non david
moment-là d'or david en fait oui non
mais c'est vraiment plaisant mais sans
journalistes irrite vous dites
alors michel
qui engagez-vous comme miss météo toutes
les miss météo ouais faut du cinéma
ouais c'est une sacrée rampe de
lancement est vraiment avancé le cours
florent maintenance et canal mais il
faut pas laisser trop longtemps ouais 1
1 en premier anticyclone vos parties
alors y'a france 2 mais aussi europe 1
avec faites entrer l'invité tous les
jours à 10h30 à dans cette émission vous
vous lâchez et j'ai même l'après sur moi
que je suis plus rapide maintenant je
vois que ma vraie carrière télé va
commencer maintenant et je vais faire un
jour un one man show cavalerie on espère
bien comme carlier
alors est-ce que vous aurez pas un jour
envie de dire ce que vous pensez
vraiment de tous les gens que vous
recevez johnny hallyday par exemple lui
dire que il ressemble à dolly parton son
père eut des trucs un peu l'art comme ça
faisait pas envie c'est un jour de alors
alors je vais
réponse très franchement j'ai débuté
avec j'étais devenu terrain recevoir
michèle y en a bien qui vous bouffe
quand même ah oui il y en a qui me
gonfle ce brave un fois de suite comme
ça sur 20 ans un moment vous non c'est
pas qui me gonfle je suis comme un
chirurgien qui les opèrent voilà moi
j'étais régulièrement et est temps en
temps évidemment je refais une jambe un
bras non
objectivement on peut pas faire ce
métier comme je le fais depuis si
longtemps si on n'aime pas les artistes
voilà bien quand même que vous détestez
dans tout ça 2 et est
un connard
un [ __ ]
ya ils sont pas là pour se défendre il
ya des grands que ceux ci n'ont michèle
laban on ya parmi ceux qui ne sont plus
là ses chers disparus certains qui m'ont
terrifié qui m'a intimidé simone
signoret m'a terrifié bon montant le
montant me foutais là un petit peu libre
il a du mal non non non mais je pense
michel 1-1 vraiment qu'on pouvait pu
voir un jeu supporte pas ça c'est un
scoop énorme
y en a pas vraiment étonnant non non
c'est alors à 1 mais il est plus là mais
je viens de parler de lui j'ai détesté
longtemps philippe guillôme qui m'a dit
que j'étais à ce but parce qu'il a fait
mais me tuer il est mort et personne ne
le connaît
le métier il tonné mais sa fille
charmante virginie
magnifique bon alors le truc le plus fou
que vous ayez fait me dites pas survolé
le mont saint michel en hélicoptère
c'est pas le sujet présenté l'émission
et pierre hardy sont d'accord on mettra
ça a été un truc de faire un direct à
redescendre oui oui surtout que sur tout
le dire est que ce n'était pas son trio
pas vraiment non alors en fait vous
seriez pas en train de vous a redit
sionisés un peu pendant que moi je me
drucké reese un peu
floue et peut-être sur le tard on n'a
pas parlé de champs elysées aussi champs
elysées on reprendra au début devant moi
la soirée madame chirac ouais elle était
mariée jacques chirac bernadette pas non
plus fictif madame chirac madame chirac
m'a dit quand ils ont quitté l'elysée
dans un climat tendu michel maintenant
nous ne sommes plus rien je suppose que
vous ne présente plus le mât soirée pour
les personnes âgées hospitalisés chez
liberdade vous trompez temps vous aurez
besoin de moi je le ferai que vous soyez
première dame ou accra les écoutes elle
est venue ici elle était assise à ta
place bernadette c'est une au regard
c'est sympa mais on est vraiment et elle
me fait boucler très bien dans beaucoup
ri et les boas la locker beaucoup plus à
gauche que beaucoup de femmes de la
gauche caviar et c'est une vraie
méchante en plus quand elle casse
quelqu'un je peux te dire que c'est toi
et c'est un spécialiste qu'il dit vrai
alors bon à part ça tout va bien mais on
a deux petits problèmes on a appris
début septembre bank parisien qu'on vous
avez volé votre portable ce qui prouve
que vous en avez un et si ça se trouve
vous connaissez le truc qui s'appelle
internet pour l'instant j'en ai de
réparer mon minitel
voilà
et puis alors que cette histoire de
maison à eygalières là on se demande
pourquoi ça fait polémique à regarder
franchement je ne comprends pas et mais
ça c'est du château de la belle au bois
dormant ça c'est pas votre maison est
beaucoup plus que ça fasse polémique
elle est bien en tous les cas cette
baraka ouais mais dans quelle chambre
d'amis tout temps
le mec
est là on arrive à la dernière question
celle que même moi je ne sais pas posée
je vais la faire on verra bien michel
vous aimez toujours autour des animaux
oui c'est qui votre chienne en ce moment
c'est
c'est une chienne de garde lucienne de
gamme ils le gardent bien je te signale
mon cher thierry oui un way que je suis
un des plus vieux mariés du paf je sais
je suis mariée depuis 40 ans voilà
c'était la peur de sincérité on se
retrouve après la pub avec anne hidalgo
aurait le sens et pour discuter avec
nous que d'actualité de la semaine à
tous
[Musique]
re bonsoir l'intérieur rebond soirée
terrienne nous sommes toujours en
compagnie de michel drucker
et nous accueillons hidalgo
allez d'algos bonsoir cette conseillère
régionale d'ile-de-france première
adjointe au maire de paris et porte
parole de martine aubry c'est devenu
comment ce soir en
vélib en ont besoin en prius voilà donc
nous en sortir et renée a lâché je suis
trop fatigué
fatigué pour être écolo et pas pour être
écoulée pour venir en mai donc une prius
après les précieuses je précise donc
c'est une voiture mixte hybride voilà en
attendant les autolib vous voulez que
tous les parisiens circulent en bus mais
on se garde comme envoyer un mec faire
un créneau avec un bus vous
alors demain aura lieu le deuxième tour
des primaires du ps
la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on est sûr
que c'est un socialiste qui va gagner là
oui c'est vrai il y aura j'espère une
socialiste face à nicolas sarkozy pour
voter aux primaires trop payé un euro
est ce que ça sera déductible des impôts
si la gauche gagne en 2012 même sans
victoire de la gauche ça peut être
déductibles des impôts la moyenne des
dons qui ont été faits au premier tour
et de 1,60 euro alors vous soutenez
martine aubry
pourquoi ce choix c'était votre témoin
de mariage et je vous ai offert une
batterie de casseroles en cuivre non
d'abord c'est un jour faire quoi pour
votre mariage vous avez offert des très
belles serviette de toilette pour tous
les jours
je loupé dans les cadeaux de marty non
surtout voilà martine aubry est une
femme que j'aime beaucoup j'ai travaillé
avec elle j'ai été conseillère à son
cabinet quand il était ministre de
l'emploi c'est une femme déterminée
c'est une femme généreuse elle est
solide et voilà je pense qu'il est temps
qu'on ait une femme présidente de la
république elle en particulier vous avez
dit martin c'est une bosseuse elle
travaille plus que 35 heures alors
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus mais en fait
les 35 heures elle les a fait aussi pour
les gens qui étaient crevés dans leur
boulot et qui avait aussi envie de
prendre du temps pour autre chose alors
vous êtes la favorite pour succéder à
bertrand delanoë à la mairie de paris en
c'est vrai qu'il a pris sa décision
quand il a vu que vous connaissiez
bambino parker
je ne suis pas sûr de le connaître par
coeur mais j'adore déroule bien il vaut
mieux il a fait une place dalida oui il
va faire une école freddie mercury vous
croyez n'ont pas écouté je ne sais pas à
côté de michel drucker que je dirais que
tout cela n'a pas imprégnés quand même
notre culture moi j'aime ça vous avez
déclaré que vous pensiez la mairie de
paris tous les matins à vaumas clients
fillon aussi oui il met du rouge à
lèvres depuis
pas mal il vous fait peur sion bon voilà
françois fillon est premier ministre et
pas très parisien où un parachutage dans
ce que dit rachida dati aussi
lorsqu'elle dit oui j'ai cru sahel le
tri d'ailleurs sans doute avec encore
plus de force souvent ne dit absolument
alors fillon a d'ores et déjà commencé
sa campagne il a acheté un plan de la
ville ne pas se perdre
comment ça un moment parce que c'est une
ville où on peut se perdre vraiment se
perdre dans paris c'est aussi se targue
de l'année on sait jamais il a battu
sion merde pas pourquoi pas premier
ministre c'est vrai ça c'est n'importe
quoi alors quand je vois un truc que
dans un truc formidable c'est que vous
savez faire la main sous le menton vous
êtes quand même la ve
élément clé rue justin pour moi je
regarde vers demain je n'ai pas peur car
je suis socialiste
et qu'il aime bien ah non mais moi la
première fois que j'ai vu hidalgo c'est
en soi disant honteux 2
la première fois que j'ai entendu parler
d'elles s'était allié au
quartier de la duchère voilà est-ce que
c'est une lyonnaise au départ est bon
d'origine espagnole de cadillac annick
chacun le sait et j'ai trouvé qu'elle
avait un physique très cinématographique
vous n'êtes pas croisé almodovar c'était
dingue et je vais vous dire quelque
chose qui va vous plaire et c'est
sincère c'est qu'on a l'impression que
le temps n'a pas de prise sur elle si
vous voyez à libyen le bo à ses débuts
et maintenant c'est la même être
moi je disais pourquoi vous n'avez
jamais été ministre
parce que ça fait dix ans que la gauche
n'est pas au pouvoir écoutent c'est un
peu compliqué comme je voulais pas trop
d'ouverture 1 a annoncé sûrement pas ça
comme une série d'algues au nom non pas
du tout eh bien non bel et bien à
indiana
trek ou karkwa
bon dans la série les mec bizarre dont
vos enfants télécharge les disques après
rust et la fouine nous accueillons
aujourd'hui orelsan
alors vous êtes rappeur et vous êtes
blanc j'ai d'autres points communs et
pierre sarkozy non
je crois qu'il fait les sons je crois
pas qu'il soit harry finalement c'est un
petit peu comme christophe lemaitre en
finale du 100 m si vous vous demandez ce
que vous foutez là quoi un blanc depuis
un an ah ça peut paraître un peu
improbable après on est en 2012 donc
l'europe ça évolue il ya eu une vraie
oui il y en a eu plein akhenaton qu'on
achète ouais j'avais pas souffert d'un
racisme anti blanc banderas non non non
votre vrai nom là c'est aurélien
cotentin vous êtes né à alençon votre
mère est institutrice et votre père
directeur d'école vous avez fait des
études de management je continue ou
votre carrière en l'air
mon premier album il s'appelait perdu
d'avancé
je crois que plus on cherche à
crédibilité mais on la trouve donc j'ai
toujours assumé ça c'est des choses dont
je parle dans mes textes grecs je prends
pas ça comme des inconvénients alors au
départ vous écoutiez plutôt nirvana et
si vos copains de basket qui vous ont
fait découvrir iam et ntm vous aviez 12
ans et quand vous parlez des gens qui
vous ont influencé vous citez un garçon
que j'ai adoré au moins pour son premier
10 et doc gynéco et vous dites qu'en doc
gynéco décrivait des pigeons picorant du
vomi de toxico ça me parlait plus que
les romances de la chanson française
c'est vrai que quand on a 15 16 ans on
va pas forcément se retrouver dans des
grandes chansons d'amour de garou ou des
choses comme ça et d'entendre des gens
qui faisait des trucs plus concrets
qu'ils viendraient qui parlait de
réalité qui par les pigeons de toxico de
vomir est c'est dans ma rue la chanson
avec alors avait fait scandale avec une
chanson intitulée sale [ __ ] sous le nom
d' or elle sonne alors je le dis tout de
suite je comprends pas pourquoi j'ai vu
ce scandale voilà c'est quand une
gonzesse vous quitte la première des
choses s'il dit sale [ __ ] quand général
franchement je comprends pas pourquoi
tout le monde vous a pris la tête avec
ça au-delà de ça même quand un gars qui
est oui sa copine s'il y avait un
équivalent de sale [ __ ] pour les gars là
est le direct alors donc à l'époque tout
le monde lui est tombé dessus j'ai deux
venue de charles manson quoi c'était un
c'était marrant enfin c'était marrant
c'était intéressant pour moi ils l'ont
fait chez vous avait été annulé des
francofolies du cat bourges printemps de
bourges daniel colling avait gardé le
concert mais il y avait des manifs les
muguets vous étiez dans l'invectivé
comme on dit ouais alors ne vais pas
baisser les bras vous sortez votre
deuxième album le chant des sirènes avec
un titre qui s'appelle suicide social
c'est très très pro vo c'est un mec qui
va se suicider cette chanson c'est une
façon de parler un peu des du
communautarisme et le fait de voir la
société sous forme de couches sociales
c'est un cliché c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui tout le monde va être
gayfriendly etc vous dites pour prouver
que t'es pas homophobe pourra bientôt
cursus des types faisait pas peur de
mettre les oignons à dos ce coup-ci non
non c'est ce que dit le personnage dans
la tension après c'est vrai que il ya
souvent des communautés qui sont plus
facilement aux français que d'autres
c'est rarement je parle aussi des
ouvriers de danger pas dans le collectif
d'ouvriers qui est qu'ils sont en train
de dire oui mais c'est contre le
prolétariat
non c'est très bien ce que vous faites
et puis alors il ya une chanson qui
s'appelle raelsan donc vous revenez sur
la polémique évidemment sale [ __ ] et
vous dites je voulais tout plaquer
quitté le son j'ai presque abandonné
sans faire ma deuxième livraison et dans
le chant des sirènes nous dit une
chanson les requins avec qui jeta fait
les suceurs qui me gratte et m'ont
poussé à cracher un deuxième disque raté
base ouvrier n'est pas du tout raté
votre deuxième liste merci va remplacer
et vous serez au bataclan le 14 décembre
le lendemain mais joeystarr qui est de
13 200 et c'est complet si on refait une
date au mois de février en bravo
qu'est ce qu'ils pensent vos parents
sont enseignants de de ce que vous
faites en ce moment comment ils ont vécu
le buzz avec sale [ __ ] maman oui michel
drucker a dit sale [ __ ] tu vois maman
faut pas m'en vouloir quand je le dis
moi mais je suis comme michel drucker
on en a discuté je leur ai expliqué ils
ont ils ont bien compris pourquoi
j'avais fait ça notamment je me rappelle
une phrase de de ma grand mère parce que
mon grand père avait un peu plus de mal
à comprendre pourquoi j'ai fait ça parce
que c'est une autre génération
comprennent pas comment on peut faire un
truc un peu provocant avec des gros mots
et c est ma grand-mère lui disais mais
moi quand on se dispute j'ai envie de
t'étrangler j'aurais pu la faire la
chance
vous avez bien je suis pas fan
je suis pas fan j'avais été choquée
c'est vrai en même temps très gêné dans
la polémique parce que je comprends bien
quand un artiste enfin l'art ne doit pas
connaître de limites voilà en même temps
quand il ya des textes qui peuvent pour
certains poussent et aussi à la violence
c'est tellement dur il ya tellement de
femmes qui se font tabasser qui meurent
tous les jours je vois tellement ça au
quotidien que je ne peux pas le retirer
de ma façon de d'entendre vos textes
idem sur les homos quoi donc je sais
qu'il ya un vrai débat sur cents
surpassant sur c'est quoi l'art jusqu'où
ça va et qui décide que c'est de l'art
ou que c'est plus de l'art mais en même
temps je ne peux pas retirer tout ce que
je vois de la vie réelle quand j'écoute
vos textes après ça pas de rapport pour
moi dans ces cas là on peut plus faire
de chansons qui parlent de cancer on
peut plus faire de chansons qui parlent
de deux meurtres de crime pour moi c'est
il faut savoir dire quand je regarde un
film je rapporte pas tout à moi non plus
et les gens sont beaucoup moins con
qu'on le croit c'est à dire que les gens
savent analyser question connerie c'est
une question de sensibilité je comprends
que l'on puisse ne pas aimer après
censure et ça reste une autre histoire
bien pas orelsan
enfin chez michel drucker dans vivement
dimanche
dimanche prochain
est spécial spécial rappeur tiens tu
devrais faire cesser la nuit bien sûr on
passe maintenant à l'actualité de la
semaine avec l'éditeur de blacko et
c'est arnaud dassier contributeurs du
site atlantico.fr que nous retrouverons
sur ce plateau après le magnéto
[Musique]
alors de montebourg a toujours paru très
satisfait de lui-même mais cette semaine
y avait quoi
c'est lui qui a imposé l'idée de la
primaire lui qui a organisé ce scrutin
lui qui est le grand gagnant du premier
tour lui lui est encore lui et le ps
dans tout ça à vrai dire le ps arnaud
s'en fout faut dire que pour lui
hollande et aubry sont aussi ringard
l'un que l'autre martine aubry françois
hollande ce sont les deux faces d'une
même pièce et au plus martine et
françois sont des losers je ne sais pas
s'ils sont capables l'un comme l'autre
de se dépasser eux-mêmes bref 70% des
électeurs de la primaire ont voté
hollande et aubry mais arnaud des crêtes
qui n'ont rien compris il a décidé que
désormais le ps devait s'aligner sur
mélenchon pour lutter contre la
mondialisation et sur eva joly pour
lutter contre la corruption
bref arlon se voulait larbitre de la
primaire alors qu'en réalité il est le
cheval de troie des thèses des verts et
de mélenchon au sein du ps résultat les
électeurs etc et d'extrême gauche vont
pouvoir désigner demain le candidat du
ps contre qui ils voteront au premier
tour en 2012 ya pas de doute la primaire
socialiste fait vraiment une idée
géniale la preuve c'est arnaud
montebourg qui l'a eu
voilà c'était l'éditeur de blagon 1 mise
en image de julien grave car le dossier
bonsoir d'un jeune entrepreneur web
blogueurs de droite comme vous dites
contributeurs du site atlantico et vous
avez un site qui s'appelle regard
d'acier ce qui est un jeu de boules
d'acier
[Musique]
bienvenue parmi nous merci alors le
succès des primaires 2,5 millions de
votants c'est pas mal ça fait 6 % des
inscrits et non pas quatre comme dit
copé 16 points sans qu'ils apprennent à
compter alors aux usa les primaires
c'est 9% et ça existe depuis 100 ans
donc en france pour les premières 6%
c'est un succès c'est vraiment une
grande avancée démocratique d'ailleurs
ça fait débat à l'ump ouais bah oui
alors qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
de ces primaires ça vous avouer ça vous
a plu oui ça m'a beaucoup plu moi oui ça
allait me fâcher avec copé sarkozy là
vous avez voté non quand même pas je
voulais je voulais voter je voulais
voter pour valls moi c'était mon
candidat plusieurs oui mais même j'ai
trouvé sincère j'ai trouvé vrai vous
avez voté non non vous en foutez le nom
de des primaires socialistes c'est pas
mon âge je me suis posé la question pour
qui j'aurais voté
j'ai déjà fin je me demandais vous avez
voté vous michel je vais voter demain
pour qui je réfléchis
penser que demain il rentre un gland
tation je suis pas sûr parce que moi je
trouve que le vrai débat idéologique ils
étaient entre montebourg et valls est
pour moi aubry et et
hollande et hollande c'est c'est la même
chose vraiment c'est presque pareil le
débat d'ailleurs le dernier était assez
ennuyeux c'était très techno c'était
très sur des mesures de dépenses
publiques de personnes oui parce que non
mais parce qu'on s'intéresse aux débats
et à regarder mais je me suis ennuyé il
ya des vraies différences les renvoyer
dos à dos n'est pas n'est pas
intellectuellement ni fondée n'y a pas
de différence dans le jt s'il ya quand
même quelques différences importantes
par exemple s'il martine aubry sur la
question européenne est allée beaucoup
plus loin sur cette idée que on peut pas
accepter le libéralisme tel qu'il est ça
fait des dégâts monstrueux on n'est pas
du tout pour le protectionnisme et la
proposer une autre voie imposer des
règles par exemple à des pays qui
viennent concurrencer les produits
européens qui ne respectent ni les
normes sociales ni environnementale
ça vous intéresse vous le retour des
socialistes
non mais là je vois qu'on accuse le
libéralisme et on sous-entend que
françois hollande état libéral de gauche
la réalité c'est que la crise dans
laquelle on est c'est la crise des
dettes des états souverains dont on me
disait que un état ne pouvait pas faire
faillite c'est ce qu'on nous entende est
ce que sont en permanence résultat les
banques se sont gavés de dette publique
et aujourd'hui on se rend compte qu
évidemment peut pas monter au ciel que
les états peuvent faire faillite la
grèce va faire probablement une forme de
faillite et toutes les banques qui ont
accepté de leur prêter en pensant que
les états ne pourrait jamais faire
faillite voilà l on était incompétente
mais c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui elles
sont en difficulté une analyse comme ça
on est pas près de sortir de la crise la
seule piste que propose ce qu'ils sont
les tenants de la thèse que vient de
nous expliqué monsieur dassier c'est
l'austérité nous on dit il faut réduire
la dette ça c'est indispensable mais il
faut réduire la dette et en même temps
soutenir la croissance et soutenant la
consommation
voilà ce qui va être le grand débat de
l'élection de 2012 c'est à dire est ce
que c'est la rigueur ou est-ce que
conversé excuse moi sens
pas la rigueur c'est la bonne gestion on
ne peut pas continuer à vivre en
permanence au dessus au dessus des
moyens du pays la responsabilité des
états et des hommes politiques de dans
la crise actuelle est extrêmement lourde
après les acteurs économiques comme les
banquiers ont fait preuve de manque de
prudence et d'une certaine incompétence
parce qu'ils ont cru à tout ça et qui se
sont je dirais jeter dans cette
spéculation de façon totalement est
raisonnable mais la cause première ce
sont les textes et des chansons vous
l'état providence et finir il est mort
il faut mais si riches pourraient payer
un peu plus d'un bien richelle par
exemple mais il faut que les dépenses
seraient d'accord pour payer plus
d'impôts jamais je n'ai absolument pas
moi aussi pas du tout ça réglera pas
l'essentiel car bien pas mais qui gagne
c'est symbolique
michel non mais ça me revient là tu vas
voter demain oui c'est pas pour les gens
de gauche mais il n'ya pas que des gens
de gauche qui ont voté progressiste oui
bon alors la vraie alliance l'a
sérieusement c'est quand même aubry ou
hollande avec bayrou parce que là ce qui
se passe non non chez les pikes bayrou
avec avec mélenchon mais ça se pose pas
en ces termes là
je crois que ça ne se pose pas du tout
en ces termes la consigne de vote ça
marche pas aujourd'hui chacun est libre
chaque citoyen considère c'est avec son
coeur est avec sa raison qu'il va voter
c'est un peu pareil pour une élection
présidentielle vous pensez que la gauche
peut gagner sans bayrou non puisque
quand on fait des études d'opinion on
voit que la la gauche en france à peu
près 40% voilà que non il faudra le
soutien de deux probablement de béraut
pour pour gagner et bien on continue à
discuter de l'actualité de la semaine
avec les vitaux de blacko 2
[Musique]
les indignés sont les enfants de la
crise et comme la crise est partout et
dans les indignés aussi au printemps
c'était l'espagne c'était d israël et
ben cet automne c'est au tour des
américains même au pays du dollar on
s'indigne contre l'argent
en un mois le mouvement lancé par une
poignée d'étudiants dans un square face
à wall street a gagné tout le pays des
milliers de personnes ont manifesté dans
une centaine de villes un tiers des
américains est favorable au mouvement et
deux prix nobel d'économie joseph
stiglitz et paul krugman soutiennent
l'indignation qui monte contre un
système où les pertes sont assumés par
99 % des américains et les produits
réservés à 1 % d'entre eux seulement
du côté de la droite républicaine
l'indignation monte aussi mais pas
contre le système plutôt contre les
pauvres dans l'esprit de big ben
côté démocrate le parti a lancé une
pétition de soutien et on se demande si
obama ne pourrait pas récupérer le
mouvement
après le 11 septembre bush a convaincu
les américains que le terrorisme était
leur pire ennemi
pourtant en 2008 l'explosion qui a
dévasté leur pays c'était celle de la
bulle immobilière
et si les financiers de wall street
était plus dangereux que les terroristes
d'al qaïda en tout cas pour l'instant le
seul milliardaire qu'obama est envoyé
par le fond c'est ben laden les autres
sont en forme merci pour eux voilà c'est
inévitable à cause de mise en image de
julien gracq
alors aujourd'hui samedi 15 octobre
c'est la journée mondiale des indignés
fixé images impressionnantes que c'est
faux et moi j'ai un frère qui habite aux
états unis ouais et il m'a raconté ça
mais c'est quand même incroyable mais
voilà et comme les américains c'est pas
des latins c'est quand ils commencent un
truc qui vont au bout il ya des chances
que ce soit pas terminer cette histoire
ce qui est terrible c'est tout ça est
parti du livre de stéphane hessel
indignez vous un petit bouquin et en
france ça marche pas il ya eu trois
pékins place de la bastille sont restés
trois jours en impression que ça marche
dans tous les pays du monde souffre là
où ça a été inventé l'indignation les
politiques doivent à partir de ce que
les peuples sont en train d'exprimer
l'un le comprendre l'analyser et faire
en sorte que les solutions sont
politiques parce que moi ma conviction
c'est que la solution ne peut être que
politique qu'est ce que vous en dites
vous que les contribuables soient
obligé de payer les pertes des banques
qui ont pris leurs risques qu'ils ont
perdu ouais par incompétence et par
appât du gain
moi je suis un libéral donc la liberté
en face c'est la responsabilité donc une
banque qui spécule et qui se plante et
bien on la ferme elle fait faillite
et puis les autres banques qui ont été
plus plus plus compétents plus sérieuse
elle trouve un espace pour pour croître
c'est comme ça que ça marche et moi je
suis indignée effectivement qu'on
demande à 99% de la population
de rogner sur leur patrimoine durement
acquis par leur travail pour aller
sauver des spéculateurs des traders qui
s'en mettent qui se mettent des millions
d'euros dans la poche tous les ans il
y a une chose mac et qui mérite beaucoup
quand on dit les politiques tous pourris
je sais bien qu'une beaucoup d'affaires
ça c'est pas vrai c'est pas bien c'est
un métier de chien c'est un métier de
chien qu'on a à perdre sa santé ses amis
souvent ses enfants ses illusions vous
n'êtes pas d'accord oui s'il faut en
faire maintenant vous me décourager un
peu plus que la chose je me présente aux
législatives m il faut que la politique
se réouvre à la société civile et moi je
suis contre le cumul des mandats la vie
politique est trop fermé sur un petit
nombre de personnes qui cumulent je
pense qu'il faut
repolitiser au bon sens du terme
c'est-à-dire redonner le goût la
politique c'est aussi avoir le goût des
autres savoir pourquoi on est ensemble
et qu'est ce qu'on va faire ensemble
c'est ça déjà le début de la politique
c'est ce que font les indignés faut que
les jeunes viennent vers la politique
qu'il nous dise pas uniquement à
l'extérieur mais aussi à un moment donné
franchissent la porte des partis
politiques vers la politique appelle
alger son portable
bien arnaud merci d'avoir été avec nous
en reste un merci d'avoir été avec nous
très bon album voilà c'était la p2 de
slt on se rentre après la pub avec le
zapping lions et nos invités du samedi
20 heures le soir nicole d'un mathiot et
sa fille
atteint du syndrome d'asperger
[Musique]
non
re re bonsoir les terrains leur avance
sur les sérieux nous sommes toujours en
compagnie d' anne hidalgo
michel drucker
et les accueillons nos invités du samedi
20 heures ce soir nicole et anne-claire
damaggio bonsoir
alors selon le ministère de la santé
l'autisme touche une personne sur 150 en
france le syndrome d'asperger guère que
vous portez anne-claire concerne environ
trente mille personnes c'est une forme
d'autisme dans laquelle les malades sont
dotés d'une intelligence hors norme on
pense que albert einstein isaac newton
mozart hitchcock bill gates était
asperger nicole pendant quinze ans vous
avez tout fait pour insérer anne claire
dans la société et vous raconter tout ça
dans un livre intitulé une épée dans la
brume publié chez anne carrière vous
nous raconter votre histoire à 20 heures
en attendant j'accueille stéphane
guillon
avoue stéphane pour guy en 2012
[Musique]
stéphane vous êtes content de travailler
chez nous et bien je ne suis pas sûr
thierry ardisson de continuer à faire ma
revue de presse chez vous je n'en suis
pas sûr je vais écrire une lettre à tous
les impétrants
travaillant à canal+ yann barthès michel
denisot et les guignols afin qu'il
reprenne mes propositions sur l'humour
en france la galéjade hexagonal et la
satire gauloise et j'irai vers des sons
j'irai nous irons chirales
chez ceux et celles qui est le sien on
les pompes les brodequins laisse abattre
et beauty
j'ai pris la grosse tête ce n'est un
secret pour personne
j'ai une hypertrophie du moi
et j'ai envie qu'on flacon le courtisent
comme senghor
fin de citation c'est bien des
sensibilités
très beau lapsus d'arnaud montebourg
chez david pujadas je ne sais pas si je
sus un arbitre à la place de je ne sais
pas si je suis un arbitre à quand une
association montebourg rachida elle
ferait des fellations il sut seraient
des arbitres pour l'occasion
exhiberait ses empreintes génitales
vingt-cinq chrétiens ont été massacrés
par l'armée égyptienne lors d'une
manifestation pacifique
si l'egypte et deux nouveaux une
dictature c'est une très bonne nouvelle
pour alliot marie elle qui ne sait pas
où aller pour les vacances de noël ils
vont pouvoir l'invité
[Applaudissements]
dimanche même si vous n'êtes pas de
gauche pour faire chier copé voter aux
primaires
et un document exceptionnel nous
parvient à l'instant dsk était tout
habillé lorsqu'il est sorti de la douche
du sofitel
c'est un isoloir à sarcelles par
dsk à voter pour martine aubry symbole
de la gauche dure l'ancien directeur du
fmi a justifié son choix
je suis prêt gauche dure
toujours qu'est ce que c'est je
jure de rien des sous
c'est être réactif
l'étranger
colloque international
quelles sont les personnes qu'on croise
hôtesses secrétaire d'un pipi
je referme
ferme sur ses positions et d'ovaires
mais qu'est ce que c'est et thierry il
ya dix ans que j'ai ouvert
moderne c'est le pas mollir jamais
quoi qu'il arrive préféré quelques
secondes de plaisir de jouer son range
ioana quitte à sacrifier un destin une
ambition tout plutôt mou est un dur
tir du sous
type de fille
alzheimer rémy pfimlin le pdg de france
télévisions s'est félicité du succès de
la nouvelle émission de france dédié
giesbert alors que celles ci n'avaient
pas été diffusées à l'antenne la semaine
prochaine rémy pfimlin devrait se
féliciter du retour de pascal sevran sur
france 2
excuse moi pascal
je voulais pas être désagréable michel
drucker était à ton enterrement oui il y
bat toujours merci
la société my sense lance une ligne de
vêtements intelligents pour bébés
équipés d'une pastille celle ci devient
bleu foncé quand bébé à froid la couleur
qui change c'est une idée qu'ils ont
piqué abbey road et courjault rose bébé
était bien il venait de naître bleus
elle l'avait mis à dormir dans le
congélateur
elle revient courjault de temps en temps
de temps en temps je suis attaché comme
vous n'êtes pas
elle nous glace
david beckham bientôt parler saint
germain le joueur anglais défilera dix
minutes par match sur la pelouse du parc
david sera un maillot rouge et bleu 100%
polyester et en maillot rouge et blanc
pour les rencontres à l'extérieur si les
blessés davines continuera la
compétition en arborant la doudoune
capuche psg au prix de 110 euros le club
salue le plus gros transfert de
l'histoire mais molle
pour ses concerts au printemps prochain
johnny est déjà à tarif réduit comme il
est lui même très réduit c'est bien
d'avoir ajusté les tarifs
dominique besnehard l'ancien agent de
ségolène royal a été ému par les larmes
de la candidate aux primaires ah ben moi
moi c était bouleversé un tout d'un coup
c'est celle à ségo qu'on aime assez plus
la foldingue habité d'une mission divine
quescom fraternité fraternité que les
cloches est tout d'un coup bas chez les
mauves chaussée greta garbo c'est la
divine c'est banal dans casablanca de 9
dans le dernier métro qu'elle quitte à
nyc les magnifiques qui fat oil va
rebondir à c'est une femme forte à le
bois tout s'arrange une terrienne puis
avec ses tenues blanches et rouges elle
va retrouver du travail chez darty a
convié ses goûts tant que de venir un
cocu de l'électroménager si elle avait
été élue elle voulait proposer un
contrat à la nation c'est darty c'est le
contrat de confiance
c'est la même chose à nous elle va faire
un malheur aller à la semaine prochaine
chaque année le point fr on passe
maintenant à nos invités du samedi 20
[Musique]
nicole et anne-claire bonsoir alors
nicole après une enfance et une
adolescence à la fois heureuse et
studieuse vous intégrer l'école des
hautes études commerciales de lille et à
22 ans vous entamer une carrière
professionnelle à paris dans l'industrie
du luxe vous grimpez quatre à quatre les
échelons de votre groupe et vous devenez
bientôt directrice du service export
avec 400 personnes sous vos ordres et
puis un jour alors que vous êtes en
week-end sur vos terres natales dans la
région de saint-brieuc vous rencontré
celui qui deviendra le père de vos deux
enfants
première enfance et anne claire
dès les premières heures de la vie
d'anne claire vous avez une étrange
intuition vous la trouvez très joli très
sage mais aussi trop distante et j'étais
même rassuré qu'elle soit très sage ça
s'est vite révélé comme étant trop sage
pour tout court sa bd facile à la bonne
appétit un sommeil impeccable mais au
fil des mois cette impression
d'impassibilité que vous avez une noté
au départ refait surface il ya quelque
chose qui ne fonctionne pas dans la
communication entre nous et à cette
époque bien sûr je présente en clair au
milieu sain qui me disent mais tout va
bien alors petit à petit les détails
s'accumulent et vous commencez à vous
poser des questions
anne-claire ne s'anime jamais tout seul
et pour qu'elle réagisse il faut la
stimuler elle semble voir son regard des
halles est absente elle est indifférente
comme si le reste du monde était un nez
en fait mais j'ignorais qu'elle est quel
était son monde à ce moment là oui elle
réagissait très bien à moi et à ma mère
et c'est tout en clair à six mois
lorsque vos regards se croisent pour la
première fois là vous avez la preuve
qu'elle voit mais son monde dites vous
la hap aussitôt il y a comme une une
frayeur de voir qui nous sommes
réellement alors vers l'âge d'un an anne
claire comment ça marche et les
branleurs
on comprenait pas pourquoi et en fait
c'est parce qu'elle avait voulu avait
appris à marcher c'est des adultes qui
l'encadraient avait les bras en l'air
elle continuer comme ça voilà alors vous
voyez qu elle naquit rien de manière
naturelle tout doit être décomposé
séquencé expliqué répéter alors
évidemment les gens vous traite à ce
moment-là de mer étouffant en temps
voulu la paix à ta fille quoi on est une
mère qui ne laisse pas son enfant faire
son expérience or je laissais mes
interparti par exemple mais ne revenait
pas ne savait pas pourquoi voilà un jour
votre vie bascule c'est la fameuse
histoire du gravier anne-claire ramasse
un gravier elle rêve c'est que ce
gravier dans la main et s'assoit par
terre oui et elle reste comme ça elle
est perdue dans son univers oui en tout
cas elle n'était pas dans le nôtre et
elle n'a pas eu le réflexe de demander
de l'aide ou bien de d'exprimer ce
qu'elle faisait et là c'est un autre
monde qu'il fallait que je découvre pas
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est qu'en
revanche anne claire développe un
langage extrêmement bien construit très
précoce à ce niveau là elle employait
déjà deux ans des subjectif qui est
quand même très étonnant vous vous
souvenez de vos premiers contacts avec
le monde vos premiers souvenirs
d'enfance
j'ai effectivement quelques souvenirs de
mon enfance
en terme de contacts et autres ce n'est
pas quelque chose auquel je apporter
réellement le soin d'un souvenir
travaillé dix roues puisque j'ai
toujours travaillé quel que soit mon
agent l'intuition raisonnée est certes à
divers degrés selon mes années de vie
puisque je suis je suis adepte de la du
paradigme qui veut que l'on apprenne en
proportion de ses années de vie mais je
me rappelle tout de même de la sphère du
gravier je me rappelle parfaitement tout
de même avoir conscience en partie de ce
que je faisais et je ne pense pas ne pas
avoir eu le réflexe de demander de
l'aide mais je me rappelle déjà à job je
me pense avoir eu déjà cette précocité
en termes de fierté ce que j'appelle
aujourd'hui sobriété est qui et qui
faisait que j'aimais mieux me
débrouiller par mes propres moyens si
limitée soit il plutôt que de demander
de l'aide alors évidemment la précocité
intellectuelle de votre fille vous
encourage visite à l'école ça va être
formidable
malheureusement l'école maternelle
s'avère terriblement compliqué et trois
ans plus tard le verdict tombe et c'est
quelque chose qui vous poursuivra tout
le temps elle serait mieux ailleurs
alors que vous votre seule ambition
c'était de la socialiser mais vous
naviguez à vue en fait vous ne
connaissez pas à ce moment là le
problème dames claire si elle ne l'est
pas frotter au moins dans lequel elle
allait vivre plus tard elle serait de
toute façon éjecté et ça a été la
terreur dans laquelle ge malheureusement
ce mot est fort mais il est réel dans
laquelle
j'ai vécu pour ne pas arriver à cette
extrémité est passé toute mon énergie à
expliquer ce qu'elle avait à trouver des
outils et à faire en sorte qu'elle reste
dans le système alors il ya des moments
excellent c'est à dire un jour dans une
kermesse vous réciter à la perfection un
poème extrêmement longs extrêmement
complexe je me rappelle effectivement
avoir eu déjà tout enfants le goût du
théâtre le goût de la représentation
mais surtout le goût des symboles
la passion des symboles devrais-je dire
ouais
alors pour qu'elle entre en primaire
pour vous battez et vous dites il ya une
phrase dans le livre que je viens de
faire échapper ma fille a rien été je
l'emmène dans l'impossible ça a été une
à tournan de mon existence puisque j'ai
fait échapper au redoublement de la
maternelle qui ne servait à rien et puis
la mettre dans l'école primaire alors
face à salé tous libres n'ont pas de
réponse j'en profite pour dire que ce
n'est pas une maladie c'est un syndrome
donc un fonctionnement différent atteint
de ce syndrome ont le porte voix la
wii personnellement j'aurais tendance à
dire qu'il ne s'agit pas même d'un
simple drôle ou kiss kiss ordonnance
autour de symptômes j'aurais tendance à
dire que c'est qu'il s'agit d'une
spécificité alors petit à petit vos
efforts portent leurs fruits
par exemple l'histoire de france qu'elle
découvre à travers la lecture elle
devient obsessionnel de l'histoire de
france oui passionnel de tous explique
plutôt je me référant serait très
volontiers à la passion que décrit et
jean racine non pas les passions ni même
l'amour inconditionnel qu'il écrit mais
vraiment la passion elle doit pas
majuscule qui le décrit comme étant le
sentiment qui a acquis tout le
flamboiement
alors vous vous êtes évidemment épuisés
par ce travail permanent et l'avait
amené à me claire chez un psy et vous
dites ces deux ans de gentils
conversation quoi ça servirait alors le
psy vous conseille un centre spécialisé
vous y allez vous dit jamais non jamais
unie qu'elle soit socialiser l'on
pouvait pas elle sera dans la vie quand
j'ai vu qu'on me disait qu'elle ne
saurait jamais lire écrire et compter et
que c'était son avenir j'ai été horrifié
et le mot et moi je me souviendrai toute
ma vie de ce moment je suis sorti avec
elle et j'ai dit elle sera dans la ville
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est comme
arrivant dans ce on se centre anne
claire voie les autres enfants elle dit
au des humains
ils seraient quelque chose d'extra
terrestres dont ça veut bien dire
qu'elle avait une perception du monde
différent du nôtre et bien sûr à charge
de trouver qui nous était ce monde et de
quoi ils étaient constitués
extraordinaire oui alors en fait le
problème c'est que vous avez du mal à
lever toutes les solutions devant vous
et vous avez du mal à faire un choix non
[Musique]
je ne pense pas que ce soit vraiment
cela tout du moins ne le dirige pas de
cette manière mais il s'agit plutôt de
puisque tout tout de suite une forme
d'art il s'agit plutôt de ciseler son
art de choix
nous asperger est autiste en général
avant une vision plutôt qu'à lille ii
scopique des choses ce qui ne signifie
pas nécessairement que le détail prime
sur la globalité mais que nous ayons une
vision de mosaïque où nous avons déjà le
motif plénier et non pas forcément total
mais bien plénier est dans son essence
propre en tête et devant les yeux et les
asperger sont globalement doux et pour
presque tout sauf pour les choses
ordinaires voilà c'est le propre du
génie certains bus mais comme lui dit
théo peters qui m'a fait l'honneur de la
préface d'un livre le génie et le
handicap se touchent souvent et nous
sommes vraiment dans cette sphère la
leur au collège c'est beaucoup plus dur
un d'abord faut y aller d pour ça faut
traverser la rue et là vous la fait
répéter quoi
pour le feu rouge et traverser la rue
regardez-vous lui fait de faire cent
fois les choses pour qu'elles se mettent
bien ces choses très simples dans la
tête en fait tout passe par un
raisonnement intellectuel scientifique
avec la condition qu'ils le comprennent
et qu'ils acceptent tous les tenants et
aboutissants d'une même situation
l'intégrer et l'appliquer or voilà ils
vont s'est dit très difficile parce que
les adolescents vous dit dans le livre
sont des prédateurs évidemment il y en a
qui l'agressent cénacle insultes y en a
qui le disent des obscénités vous avez
vécu ça comme un
jeu lettre disait
je vais très vite assimilé à une veillée
d'armes
d'accord mais surtout peut-être l'auteur
et je lui en vendre grass qui m'a
peut-être le plus sauvé durant cette
période ou du moins qui m'a aidé à tenir
et jean raspail et notamment avec l'une
de ses citations que j'aime beaucoup
quand on représente une cause presque
perdu il faut vous dire sur son cheval
sonner les trompettes et tenter la
dernière sortie sans quoi l'on meurt au
fond de la forteresse que plus personne
n'a siège car la vis en italie vous êtes
dit vous une mère par bribes parce que
vous êtes évidemment sa maman mais aussi
son éducatrice un psychologue son
esclave son otage sa juge sa
tortionnaire en face à un rapport
extrêmement compliqué la douceur on
essaie bien sûr mais il faut une telle
intensité pour les pour les faire réagir
et agir mais qu'on est obligé d'être
très intense alors voilà et puis un jour
en regardant la télévision vous le
découvrez quelles portes le syndrome
d'asperger heures et là vous êtes un peu
soulagés vous dites ça existe hélas est
presque une victoire je me suis reconnu
je me dis mais j'ai exagéré j'avais
raison c'est ça qu'on votre maman vous a
dit voilà tu es une asperger ça vous a
fait quoi
j'ai tout de suite en revue les aspects
qui pouvait être désagréable dans ma vie
future j'ai tout de suite vu l'aspect
stigmatisant
mais je me suis
10 puisque j'en avais l'habitude que le
mieux que je pouvais faire c'était de le
fabriquer enfin comment dirais-je de le
de leur créer de leur créer de me
l'approprier d'en faire un art de choix
et surtout de le transformer en joue et
philosophique ans je me dis jamais
asperger ni différentes ni quoi ni autre
chose de ce genre mais je me dis
brodeuses de brume
alors c'est magnifique ce que j'explique
entre autres la couleur blanche que je
parte ce soir et vous vous en souffrez y
aider des méthodes de votre mère c'est
quand elle vous dresser à pour traverser
la rue booth était insupportable pour
vous
comme tout adolescent je vois comme tout
allait donner sens et nous avons à coeur
de soigner notre nos effets néanmoins je
veux bien que nos relations ont toujours
été ont toujours été et serons toujours
racinienne dans le plein dans un sens
plus ou moins totale du terme et en ce
sens ma foi l'amour que je lui porte n'a
pas nécessairement besoin d'être
d'être confirmée par une infection par
une affection de monstres démonstrative
alors vos efforts de socialisation
s'avère payant vous lui apprenez à
converser à communiquer alors elle
décroche son brevet en fait des études
de communication à l'université de
toulouse ensuite un master de sciences
politiques et vous êtes major de votre
promotion à la sortie
alors qu'est ce que vous diriez à un
couple à des parents à une maman qui a
un enfant qui porte un syndrome
comparables
je lui dirais surtout de ne pas paniquer
et je dirais de
d'expliquer d'aller convaincre ne jamais
abandonner pour obtenir ce qu'ils
sentent en tant qu'un puissions des
parents ce qu'ils sentent qu'il est bon
de faire pour son enfant d'une part
d'autre part devrait tout de suite pour
un diagnostic très précoce car c'est ce
qui fait défaut en france nous avons un
retard considérable en matière d'autisme
et d'aspe rigueur en france et ensuite
de lutter et de proposer des solutions
pour qu'il y ait un accompagnement
qu'ils soient parfaitement personnalisé
pour que les asperger et ceux qui ont
différence invisible et ne place
légitime à leur hauteur dans nos
entreprises dans nos sociétés car ils
sont capables du meilleur et nous offre
une vision du monde totalement
différente justement vous projetez
commandant l'avenir hunter tout d'abord
j'espère un jour méritait pleinement la
qualification d' être humainement belle
sera mon premier objectif
et j'ai cependant ce que tout le reste
va se redonnant c'est au tour puisque la
première décision vient du coeur et
l'intelligence doit dont nous sommes
tous exposit air doit faire ce que notre
coeur décide
[Applaudissements]
tu te rends bien ça c'est un métier
formidable ça permet de rencontrer des
gens qu'on n'aurait jamais rencontré
vous avez envie de fonder une famille
être maman
ce n'est pas dans mes projets immédiats
partie des choses cette beauté humaine
que vous revendiquez vous l'avez dit
nous le mot de la fin
j'aurais tendance à dire que la
normalité n'est pas le summum de ce qui
peut s'atteindre sa sébile
voilà c'était salut les terriens
rendez vous samedi prochain ici à la
même heure et d'ici là sur canalplus.fr
avec en bonus le top des vannes les
vitaux de l'ago l'édito des gréements
salut les terriens
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater le in
lardy tube abonnez vous je m'étais un
peu ce bleu